[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue leur point de
vue c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine de débats et
des changes de préférence
contradictoires nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir aujourd'hui nos deux
médecins préférés bonsoir dr pelloux
pour cela vous êtes médecin urgentiste
mais aussi écrivain
vous avez été longtemps chroniqueur à
charlie hebdo est votre dernier livre
qui est d'ailleurs un recueil de vos
chroniques urgence de vivre a été publié
aux éditions du cherche midi
et puis laurent alexandre bonsoir à vous
aussi vous êtes médecin mais pas que
puisque vous êtes aussi un entrepreneur
à succès notamment le fondateur de
doctissimo vous êtes aussi essayiste et
votre dernier livre
jouissez jeunesse a été publié aux
éditions lattès
comment son site vous pouvez bien par un
sujet médical sanitaire le fameux
variant indien même si le gouvernement
de ce pays aimeraient bien qu'on
l'appelle autrement en tout cas ce
variant se diffuse au royaume uni on
parle même outre-manche de troisième
vague possible 3500 à 4000 nouveaux cas
par jour en france pour l'instant il est
assez peu présent moins d'une centaine
de cas répertoriés cependant des mesures
sont prises pour diminuer
l'entrée de personnes chez teal d'être
contaminés écoutez ce qu'en disait
gabriela talent c'était la semaine
dernière ce qui est certain c'est qu'il
ya une nouvelle donne avec le
développement du variant 10 indiens ou
royaume uni que l'allemagne a annoncé il
ya quelques heures ou quelques jours des
mesures supplémentaires notamment en
termes d'isolement pour les personnes
qui proviennent du royaume uni et que la
france va prendre des mesures semblables
et donc mettre en place un isolement
obligatoire pour les personnes qui
viendraient du royaume uni voilà les
mesures en question sont mises en place
depuis aujourd'hui il y a d'abord des
tests mais ça c'est valable pour tous
les gens qui entrent en france des tests
récents qui ont dû être faits pour les
voyageurs il ya aussi une limitation
à des motifs impérieux limitation donc
des entrées sur notre territoire et puis
quand on arrive du royaume uni et bien
il ya sept jours d'isolement alors cet
isolement il est laissé à l'appréciation
des personnes qui arrivent c'est à dire
qu'on ne les met pas dans un hôtel ou
dans un lieu fermé même s'il peut y
avoir des contrôles de police
est ce que le système est suffisamment
coercitif nos confrères de france info
ont posé la question ce matin à clément
bonne le secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes on le fait pour les pays
dans lesquels la situation de variants
ou sanitaire en général est la plus
dégradée
on surveille et on fait des réponses
proportionnées si on avait une
dégradation de la situation sanitaire
britannique plus de variants ou plus de
circulation du variant chez nous nous
prendrions des mesures encore renforcée
patrick pelloux est ce qu'on en fait
suffisamment
côté français pour ne pas pour que par
dans ce variant indien ne se diffuse pas
dans notre pays il est déjà là toute
façon dont qui va suivre une courbe qui
est la courbe de l'écologie normal de ce
virus on a déjà eu plein de variants et
donc il est là il pourrait se développer
maintenant plus variés anglais bah c'est
possible c'est possible le seul rempart
qu'on est là encore c'est de vacciner la
population
donc ça c'est sûr mais et ça vous aura
pas échappé il ya une envie d'en finir
de la population allait les terrasses et
tant mieux on était pris d'assaut les
théâtres les musées tourner tout le
monde a envie de revivre ce qu'on
comprend mais l'épidémie est encore là
elle va continuer à évoluer là vous
parlez du variant indien mais peut-être
que c'est les variants indien dont il
faudrait parler comment ça va se
développer
nul ne le sait à quelle croissance et
quelle virulence ça va avoir
on ne sait pas et donc là on est encore
à nouvelle phase pour sa crotte l'ailé
mais les britanniques disent qu'il ya il
va y avoir peut-être chez eux une
troisième vague bas il faut en tenir
compte je pense pas que ça arrive tout
de suite parce que
on va vers les chaleurs de l'été l'année
dernière ça s'était calmé pendant l'été
mais voilà il va falloir se tenir prêt
en août mais les mesures prises depuis
ce matin ils iront au royaume uni elles
sont elles pourraient laisser visionné
pendant une semaine ça vous paraît bien
réglée oui ça me paraît bien réglée si
les gens sont quand même quelque part
surveiller ce que ce témoignage que j'ai
eu d'amis qui était allé tantôt aux
états unis totaux en angleterre où ils
ont des coups de fils réguliers voir ils
sont tracées avec leurs portables et
donc bien sûr ils peuvent toujours
s'échapper parce que ce n'est pas la
prison
évidemment mais disons qu'ils ont réussi
à essayer de contenir et à deux et a
limité les personnes sur leur sur leurs
déplacements
mais c'est un vrai enjeu c'est à dire
que là on sait maintenant l'importance
de ces mesures aux frontières on l'a vu
avec le brésil
on l'a vu avec l'inde maintenant on le
voit avec l'angleterre parce que
l'épidémie est toujours là alors vive la
reprise de la société un vive la reprise
de la société on est tous pour mais ça
veut dire même si je sais qu'on en a
assez c'est garder encore les gestes
barrières gardées le masque et surtout
vacciner vacciner vacciner parce que
c'est notre seul rempart à sept minimes
on va reparler de la dangerosité de ce
variant mais sur ce point très concret
laurent alexandre votre point de vue est
ce que le système mis en place par la
france pour les voyageurs en provenance
du royaume uni et au bon niveau de
coercition on peut pas aller beaucoup
plus loin parce qu'elle ne sera pas
accepter politiquement tire les gens
patrick à raison vol sortir du
confinement en ont assez et puis ya
effectivement un risque que les variants
indien soit plus dangereux mais on peut
pas crier au loup chaque semaine ce que
les gens vont crac crac et et à la fin
ce sont les complotistes qui vont
l'emporter et les gens qui s'opposent à
toutes les mesures sanitaires
on a vu
le scandale et les insultes de bigard il
ya quelques jours
ce courant là pour est populiste
pourrait être réalisé si on met en place
des mesures trop fortes au moment où les
français en ont ras-le-bol vous-même
pardon je vous interromps vous avez été
attaqué très très très violemment pour
être favorable aux vaccins c'est un
signe qu' il n'y a pas de consensus sur
j'ai traité
chez hanouna d'assassins par quelqu'un
qui considère que la crise est liée à l'
influence mortifère des rothschild et
que ce sont les rothschild qui ont créé
tout ça oui
et cet extrait où je suis traité
d'assassin parce que je suis pro vax
parce que je suis pro vaccin a été vue
plus d'un million de fois rien que sur
twitter extrême gauche par mon poste de
l'année exactement de la démission
d'hanouna donc oui il ya un courant très
fort de défiance politique complotistes
qui est alimenté par les gens que l'on
sait bigard qui veut que les ministres
crève et qui dit que busin est une
[ __ ] et que le pass sanitaire c'est
pire que l'étoile jaune pendant la shoah
et c'est donc il ya un mouvement une
montée en puissance d'un d'un populisme
complotistes qui est important donc il
faut qu'on soit mesurée sur les mesures
que l'on prend parce que les français en
ont ras le bol alors bien sûr patrick a
raison la seule sortie c'est la
vaccination
mais au moment où nous nous parlons là
on a fait des progrès dans la
vaccination il n'y a que 17 courses 16%
des français ces catastrophes sont
vaccinés non mais ça a au moment où nous
parlons la terreur on est aujourd'hui on
est en nous et arman nous a dit 20
millions ça fait plus de ce médicament
qui ont les deux qui ont uni les gaz
avec les deux occasions une injection
ses 11 millions de personnes c'est ses
ennemis pour cent des faits celle là des
français qui ont des feux des français
qui ont une injection maintenant il y en
a plus
mais les deux injections qui donne
l'efficacité notamment sur les variants
un peu exotiques comme le variant indien
mais en réalité c'est les 11 millions
ces 16% la population donc 85 % de la
population n'est pas protégé
correctement me contre contre le variant
indien c'est donc il va falloir
accélérer si on veut éviter d'avoir un
quatrième couvre-feu ou confinement cet
été ou en septembre aux questions sur
twitter le variant indien et il
sous-estimé en france vous ne répondez
oui à 60 %
et puis il ya cette affirmation de
catherine sur youtube
j'aimerais bien avoir votre point de vue
là-dessus patrick peloux ce variant
n'est pas plus dangereux que les autres
et ne provoque pas l'hécatombe annoncé
dans sa alors vu ce qui s'est passé en
inde
ggd doute mais c'est ce que je vous
disais c'est à dire qu'en fait qu'on sur
sa virulence sur sa pathogénicité pour
voir sa tombe et dacquois qui se diffuse
plus viril plus vite et les virulents
plus méchant c'est à dire qu'il va faire
plus date un peu plus monnaire toucher
plus gravement les patients à risque on
reste pour répondre à cette
téléspectatrice
on reste toujours avec les mêmes
personnes à risque d'ailleurs l'obésité
l'hypertension mal traiter le diabète
mal traités donc on reste toujours avec
avec cela mais on est toujours dans la
tempête de la crise
on n'essaie pas parce que d'un coup on
enlève ce carcan nécessaire de faire
revivre la société mais ce que vient de
dire à alexandrie tout à fait juste à
dire qu'en fait ça peut se faire si on
vaccine
or la vaccination désolé mais on est
encore trop lent a alors là ils ont
enfin ouvert à tout le monde
tout le monde disait ça va être des
embouteillages sur les centres de
vaccination bat as non parce qu'on a usé
les gens on a usé les gens et les gens
n'y vont pas c'est trop compliqué aya il
ya des fois alors ne parlons même pas de
cette bêtise du qr code où il faut avoir
fait à la fois saint cyr polytechnique
sciences po l'ena pour comprendre le qr
code
ah je rappellerai jean laurent alexandre
qui est médecin qui a fait voilà je sais
et les normes je lui rappelais que tout
le monde n'a pas de smartphones en
france tout le monde ne sait pas faire
fonctionner les applications vous avez
les personnes âgées vous allez personnes
qui comprennent pas mais moi j m'a fallu
une heure pour comprendre et faire
exagère de la rue jarry si si si l'on
rajoute passé c'est terrible c'est
terrible on a est alors qu'ils devraient
et quand on voit ce qui s'est passé dans
d'autres pays notamment évidemment s'ils
t'ont les états unis où là ils ont
réussi à vacciner mais mais mais par
centaines de milliers par millions dans
des week-ends les gens et nous nous
sommes toujours toujours à l'art a
toujours à la traîne à une question de
gisèle à laquelle vous pouvez peut-être
répondre laurent alexandre questions sur
youtube
difficile d'estimer la fréquence de la
diffusion de ce variant indien l'afa
corse de sa diffusion oui la france fait
rarement des séquençages sur le nouveau
contaminés elles n'étaient équipées que
de deux laboratoires spécialisés dans
cette procédure
oui le professeur froguel froguel à
lille s'en est plaint depuis plusieurs
mois on a très peu séquencer les virus
en france et donc on n'a pas une
cartographie des variants et les pays où
on a beaucoup beaucoup séquencé en
france on a très peu séquencer attendait
pardon je vous coupe mais je vais parler
de moi tant pis ça n'a aucun intérêt
moi j'ai attrapé la copie de début avril
au bout de 2 alors j'ai fait mon premier
test on m'a dit vous êtes positif et au
bout de cinq jours on m'a envoyé un truc
en disant c'est le vario anglais ccsa
séquençage n'ont donc ça a l'air de se
alors m ça dépend c'est pas forcément
mais le séquençage en regardant à fond
la rn du virus on en fait encore très
peu on en fait plus maintenant qu'il ya
six mois on en fait encore très peu et
si on veut avoir une bonne estimation de
la part du variant indien des variants
indien ou d'autres variantes il faut
conséquence une partie importante des
virus en circulation aujourd'hui on ne
fait que des petits échantillons mais
c'est exact mais en fait nous qui sommes
sur le terrain ou laisser les mêmes
malades c'est à dire que qu'il soit
indien brésil vous savez pas vous
patrick voyer arrivée aux urgences
qu'elle narre si c'est le var y ont
amené le roi de moyens de leur bonheur
non et c'est les mêmes pathologies c'est
les mêmes maladies donc en fait ça a pas
beaucoup d'importance
après en effet il ya une érudition à
avoir sur l'évolution sur l'épidémie ça
c'est la science ça pour toujours du
savoir et donc de la connaissance mais
c'est pas notre priorité
nous notre priorité à chaque fois c'est
de savoir si le patient il va s'en
sortir juste avec beaucoup d'oxygène des
bonus de corticoïdes ou si d'un coup il
va falloir l'intuber le ventiler le met
en position couchée sur le ventre le met
en réanimation ccsa l'ubs ainsi patrick
6-2 dans le futur arrivaient des
variants plus dangereux ou avec un air 0
beaucoup beaucoup plus élevé il faudrait
qu on les diagnostique viti oui il
faudrait et il faudrait qu'on voit les
kloster de ces masses peluche plus
méchant oui ça ça supposerait un
séquençage de masse - virus des maisons
sur le seul front en fait ça changera
pas grand chose parce que si en effet
par malchance
on a un variant qui devient hyper
virulent avec une contagiosité
épouvantable ça voudra dire de re
dégainer le confinement de remettre des
mesures mais on sera toujours incapable
de dire pourquoi écouter vous avez le
variant anglais et puis rien n'empêchera
que d'un coup vous avez les anglais les
confinements régional savoir les autres
dans les zones à ça parce que vous vous
êtes médecin est pas
lecteur dans le marc de café mais à
combien ce que vous estimiez le risque
d'une d'une troisième vague en france
liées au nouveau variant est ce que
c'est c'est un risque / 3 / 5 / 10
recettes et lorient ils sont voués mon
avis mon intuition mais je peux dire une
grosse blinde rien mon intuition du
moment vous êtes de celles en boule de
cristal c'est cet été très faible une
reprise à l'automne si on vaccine pas
massivement
je dirais entre 10 et 25% d'une
troisième crise à l'automne si on
vaccine très rapidement et qu'on monte à
75 % de la population vaccinée jeudi que
le risque est faible parce que même les
variants indien reste sensible aux
vaccins arn messagers d'accord avec
cette manifestation voilà je me garderai
bien ce qu'est ce qui est sûr c'est vu
qu'on a déjà fait un tour de l'épidémie
je pense qu'en effet ça ça va diminuer
sur la le ce qui s'est passé sur le même
modèle que l'année dernière sans doute à
mon avis avec la chaleur de l'été et
cetera et puis on va rester avec un
rythme de fond de toute façon d'accord
et c'est là où on verra en effet en
septembre si ça commence à remonter etc
je me garderai bien par rapport à
certains grands professeurs forcément
grand de l'ap-hp qui ont encore 10 à une
semaine que dans quinze jours on serait
tous morts
bon ça je n'y crois pas du tout un seul
instant je pense plutôt que c'est à bas
bruit et pour donner de petits je pense
que toute façon cette épidémie eva va se
casser progressivement va y avoir de
plus en plus de variants parce que ça
c'est inhérent
si j'ai bien compris un d'histoire
virale et à cette écologie et ça va
devenir plus en plus et sa barre par
contre 4 sûr c'est que faut s'attendre à
ce qu'on ait des vaccins qui colle
beaucoup plus aux variants et donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que là on
est en train de se planter complètement
sur l'organisation de la vaccination
donc moi j'engage le gouvernement à
remettre ça sur l'établi parce que ça se
trouve ce qu'on a déjà vacciné en
septembre octobre va falloir les
vaccinés avec dr puis ça veut dire une
organisation qui soit beaucoup plus
performant un mot encore de nos
internautes solide patrick sur youtube
qui considère que l'état a les européens
l'état français et les européens sont
conscients des risques de ce variant et
d'ailleurs les restrictions qu'il qui
ont été prises le montre juste voulez
votre point de vue sur le mas coulet vu
qu'aux états unis joe biden a dit si
vous avez été vaccinées de voix
vous poussez vous avez eu deux doses de
vaccin plutôt vous pouvez enlever le
masque en france on décidera pas ça
avant la fin du mois de juin
vous pensez qu'on pourrait dire déjà on
n'a plus besoin du masque à l'extérieur
laurent alexandre rocha nantes
quand on est doublement vacciner on n'a
pas besoin du max en extérieur c'est une
certitude
sauf que comme on ne va pas mettre un
signe distinctif sur la poitrine quand
on est vaccinés comment les autorités ça
pour savoir dessiner il ne l'est pas je
considère aujourd'hui qu'il faudrait
mieux supprimer l'obligation du masque
en extérieur parce qu'il faut donner un
petit peu de liberté que les gens en ont
vraiment marre et qu'on est en fait dans
une phase de diminution rapide de la
circulation du virus donc
personnellement je suis en tant que
citoyen en tant que père de famille en
tant que médecin favorable à ce qu'on
supprime immédiatement l'obligation de
porter le masque en extérieur pour tout
le monde puisqu'il n'est pas capable on
n'est pas capable de séparer les
vacciner les non vaccinés
non mais moi je pense qu'il faut le
garder je pense qu'il faut le garder
parce que on est on a gagné déjà la
partie avec ce qu'a voulu le président
de la république contre la vie
d'ailleurs du comité scientifique et
d'un certain nombre d'experts qui
voulait confier totalement la france
arrêté tout arrêter les écoles etc
je pense qu'il ya une décision politique
qui était juste et le président a eu
raison bon maintenant il faut garder
quand même l'idée que l'épidémie
continue j'aurais juste rappelé par
rapport aux masques en extérieur que le
prince le début de l'épidémie en italie
ça avait été un marathon en extérieur et
s'inviter le début que à mulhouse avait
été aussi dans une esplanade qui était
qui était quasiment à ciel ouvert où ça
s'est produit donc il y à il ya une
réalité il ya les chinois ont fait une
étude en ré expliquant l'importance du
masque donc je pense que c'est pas le
moment
maintenant que ça soit réévaluée fin
juin ça me paraît cohérent si les
chiffres continuent à descendre et ici
on augmente la vaccination parce que en
effet je suis d'accord avec vous ce sera
impossible de dire aux gens alors toi tu
portes demain si on fait ça et là on
aurait un vrai risque de relancer
l'épidémie et de repartir pour un tour
et alors là c'est épouvantable merci
autres
sujet qui n'a rien à voir même si il y à
aussi santé publique france qui est
mobilisée la campagne contre la
discrimination des personnes lgbt cette
campagne vous l'avez peut-être vu ou sur
vos écrans de télévision ou sur des
affiches ou sur les réseaux sociaux
l'objectif est selon le slogan de cette
campagne de faire la différence face à
l'intolérance voici quelques visuels de
cette campagne si vous n'avez pas
forcément vu ce sont des affiches que
l'on peut apercevoir dans l'espace
public
oui ma coloc et lesbiennes voilà oui ma
fille est lesbienne
oui ma petite fille et trans
oui mon père est gay alors on peut se
demander pourquoi est-ce-que santé
publique france fait ce genre de
campagne dans la mesure où on s'attend
plutôt à des campagnes par exemple
sanitaires sur l'importance des gestes
barrières et bien c'est la directrice
générale de cet organisme donc officiel
qui dépend du ministère de la santé qui
donne la réponse
elle explique que les discriminations
ont des répercussions délétère et
durable sur la santé physique et mentale
des personnes en termes de troubles
psychologiques et identitaire de
consommation de substances psychoactives
de santé sexuelle dégradé c'est donc un
enjeu majeur de santé publique et
d'égalité
il est primordial que nous soyons tous
mobilisés c'est tout le sens de notre
campagne devant alexandre
que pensez vous de ce type de campagne
que certains français considèrent comme
entre guillemets intrusive c'est à dire
qui fait que l'étape sort peut-être de
son rôle purement sanitaire
alors je suis de notoriété publique pro
mariage gay pro pma projet p a donc
favorable à ce que les gays et les
familles atypiques puisse se constituer
et avoir des enfants mais la
médicalisation de cette affaire me
choque
cette campagne n'aurait pas dû être fait
par santé publique france ce n'est pas
un problème de santé en réalité on fait
comme si l'homosexualité était une
maladie c'est pas ce n'est pas la santé
publique france de s'occuper de ça il y
à d'autres organismes autour de l'est
à qui aurait pu lancer cette campagne je
trouve que c'est maladroit d'autre part
moi je suis certaines associations
notamment associations gays ne sont pas
très contente de cette campagne parce
que elle considère que cela réduit
l'identité des gens à leur orientation
sexuelle
or il ya plein de gars qui ne veulent
pas être identifiés par leur sexualité
ils veulent être identifiés par leurs
positions politiques leur existence leur
activité culturelle et ils ne veulent
pas une étiquette gay or dans cette
campagne on donne une étiquette
mon papa est gay ma petite soeur et
trans mon grand frère et lesbiennes on
met une étiquette essentielles y
mattison on est lancé on essentialisme
comme d'habitude mais on voit bien qu'on
est en plein aux cultures où on doit
caractériser tout le monde par sa race
sa religion son ethnie alors que nous
sommes tous des citoyens français libres
et qu'on n'a pas être caractérisé par
notre sexualité on fait ce qu'on veut
entre adultes consentants et moi je suis
choqué personnellement par cette
campagne
bien que favorable à la défense des
droits des minorités sexuelles
patrick peloux moi je suis totalement
pour cette campagne
parce que je suis je
j'aurais pu figurer dans la fiche ma
fille est lesbienne elle va épouser sa
compagne j'en suis très heureux et c'est
formidable et elle vit cette homophobie
elle le vit et cote 1 soir on en a parlé
mais vous êtes sidéré de ce que vous
entendez de la violence qu'elle subit
encore aujourd'hui encore aujourd'hui et
ça deviendra ajouté et c'est une étude
une réalité d'accord c'est un véritable
combat tous les jours ce qui fait que
d'accord sur ce que je comprends ce que
ce que ce que vous dites sur eux sur les
critiques mais la lutte contre
l'homophobie est devenue une vraiment
quelque chose d'absolument essentiel je
le vois au samu de paris ou d'un coup
des gays qui se promène dans certains
quartiers sont d'abbas et violenté une
amie lesbienne le raconter ça le jour où
elle s'est mise à apprendre le krav maga
parce qu'elle me dit parce que dans des
quartiers
j'ai peur d'accord c'est la campagne
café hubert d'affichage en disant vous
pouvez en fait rentrer dans nos voitures
hubert sans être insultées si vous êtes
homosexuel et si vous vous embrasser on
en est là yahia une véritable
discrimination c'est
anticonstitutionnellement inqualifiable
parce que dans la constitution nous
sommes à l'égalité nous sommes tous
égaux or ce n'est plus du tout respecté
à l'heure actuelle pour eux alors il ya
vraiment je veux dire le combat lgbt
trans et c'est vraiment un combat
ultramodernes
moi je dois vous avouer que j'avais pas
compris au départ quand françois
hollande avait lancé le mariage gay
j'avais pas compris la priorité je lui
ai enfin ça me paraissait naturel didier
bès oui c'est naturel il n'y a pas de
débat
et quand j'avais mesuré et vu les
manifestations la haine ce qui s'était
passé dans les rues je m'étais dit oui
il ya un vrai sujet de société
mais le combat sur le combat de
l'homophobie et doit être une priorité
et c'est pour ça que cette campagne
elle est absolument essentiel essentiel
je vais laisser la parole à l'horizon
mais je voudrais intervenir dans le
débat pour dire qu' il peut alors là on
est passé de cette campagne au mariage
homosexuel donc cette réforme portée par
par françois hollande et christiane
taubira
il me semble qu'il peut y avoir débat
sur ce sujet sans forcément qu'il y ait
n veut dire on peut débattre de savoir
s'il n'est pas préférable pour des
enfants parce qu'en fait c'est ça notre
jeu d'avoir un père et une mère
peut-être qu'on n'est pas forcément dans
noir ou dans le blanc oui est la
première des tolérances ça serait
probablement de lutter contre les
discriminations dans les cours d'école
qui est un lieu ultra violent en fait et
où il se passe pas grand chose
or c'est peut-être là où il faudrait
intervenir
il faut intervenir dans des lieux où en
fait même le vocabulaire la raillerie
nas pas et souvent confondu avec ça il
faut lutter contre ça on lutte pas
contre l'humour parce que moi je je je
plaisante largement avec mes amis
homosexuels etc et on se marre et on
continuera à rire c'est quand d'un coup
il ya un débordement et où le
vocabulaire devient violent ce nom et
devient vraiment une oppression et je
vous assure la discrimination pour
trouver un logement
vous avez certes un lieu où ils peuvent
pas rentrer alors bien sûr après vous
dit qu'il ya des bars homos etc mais est
évidemment parce qu'il ya des bars où
ils sont montrés du doigt on se moque
d'eux où ils sont et c'est ça hein un
collègue qui est travaillé au samu m'a
raconté que son son fiancé dans le métro
a été bousculée a été renversé et
balancer comme ça dans l'escalier en
disant ça ce côté c'est pas possible
d'entendre ça en 2021 et c'est pour ça
que toutes les initiatives de lutte
contre l'homophobie
il faut les prendre mais vous pensez que
ce genre de campagnes efficaces pour
alexandre est ce que elle ne convaincra
pas que ceux qui sont déjà certains qui
fit m
évidemment ce genre de comportement que
décrit patrick pleau d'inacceptable
c'est difficile à dire il faudrait
évaluer ce type de campagne en plus ça
mélange beaucoup de choses sur lequel le
consensus social et différenciée dire
que aurait dit il ya une acceptation du
mariage gay qui est très forte dans la
société et même dans des parties que
l'on aime estimé estimait plus
conservateurs comme le rassemblement
national il ya une majorité de gens qui
sont favorables au mariage gay et qui
sont mariés qui sont favorables à la pma
d'ailleurs l'année dernière jordan
bardet là
le numéro deux du grand sable nationale
avait dit que le mariage gay est un
acquis social et qu'il était hors de
question de le supprimer si marine le
pen ne gagnaient la présidentielle de
2022 donc là dessus il ya un consensus
social en faveur à 1 en faveur du
mariage gay en revanche sur le statut
des trans et sur la publicité qu'il faut
donner aux trans il n'y a pas de
consensus et personnellement sans du
tout m'opposer aux droits des trans je
considère qu'aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
par exemple aux états unis est dangereux
et on voit des gamins qui demande à être
opéré à l'adolescence alors qu'en
réalité ils ne vont pas rester
durablement avec une sensibilité trans
et que c'est juste une phase
d'adolescence et compte tenu de
l'importance de la mutilation sexuelle
que représente le changement de sexe je
pense qu'il faut faire attention et
présentés sur les murs de paris
l'homosexualité et la transsexualité
sous un jour identiques comme si c'était
la même chose alors dans un cas il ya
une mutilation sexuelle compliqué à
gérer à laquelle je ne m'oppose pas sur
les gens qui sont sensibles
enfin durablement de sensibilité trans
mais sur lequel je m'oppose aux états
unis on voit des gamins qui à force de
d'être finalement instrumentalisés par
des associations ce transfuge de sexe et
le et le regrettent des gravement
quelques années plus tard parce que le
changement de sexe a des conséquences
absolument majeur sur le plan sexuel
bien sûr mais sur le plan psychologique
aussi donc je suis réservé à ce qu'on
présente la transexualité sous un jour
aussi neutre alors que c'est un sujet
très compliqué et je ne voudrais pas
qu'on ait la dérive américaine en france
je me donne juste les points de vue nos
internautes et après bien sûr vous
prenez la parole sheikh patrick peloux
selon vous la campagne lgbt mais départ
santé publique france est elle politique
et la réponse est oui il ya 80% ce qui
ce n'est pas forcément d'ailleurs un
jugement de valeur pour savoir si elle
est bonne ou mauvaise car la politique
c'est une dangereuse du débat public
didier sur youtube
c'est juste pour gagner des électeurs
aux élections et nicole sur lefigaro.fr
ça devient lourd
toutes ces campagnes de minorité puis un
autre point de vue plutôt négatif
françois sur youtube
je n'ai rien contre les orientations
sexuelles des gens dans la mesure où ils
sont majeurs et consentants mais ce
battage à la fin c'est de la surenchère
dans les rangs
non non c'est pas de la surenchère
délirante parce que nous sommes le pays
des droits de l'homme où on a toujours
influencé largement le développement des
droits humains il faut regarder ce qui
se passe dans d'autres pays
1 vous avez vu ce qui s'était passé en
inde ou dans des pays d'afrique ou d'un
coup les homosexuels sont martyrisés
sont assassinés ce qui s'est passé en
russie il ya eu un un reportage d'une
violence inouïe sur arte mais ça c'est
pas en transe pendant mais c'est pas en
vendant mais nous donnons un tempo c'est
ce que je dis à guillaume c'est que nous
donnons un tempo c'est à dire qu'à
partir du moment où d'autres pays si
nous on ne faisait rien si nous
n'allions pas au combat des idées pour
défendre l'homosexualité on ne serait
pas en accord avec ce qui a conduit
l'histoire de notre pays
d'accord quand on se promène à los
angeles et qu'on voit justement le fait
qu' il ya il ya cette communauté
homosexuelle qui a finalement pignon sur
rue qui sait existait qui cohabitent il
n'y a aucun problème
on se dit mais on a le ce prisme de se
dire que c'est comme ça partout non ce
n'est pas comme ça partout quand vous
rentrez à l'intérieur des terres
américaines c'est extrêmement difficile
et il ya ceux il faut il ya ce n'est pas
un petit combat parce que c'est un
combat des droits de l'homme c'est un
combat profondément humaniste de
défendre ces personnes contre cette
homophobie et je vous assure je vous
assure que quand vous parlez avec des
homosexuels avec des gens même à paris
ou en province d'accord vous parler avec
eux vous
vivez au quotidien ce qu'ils vivent mais
je vous assure que c'est très difficile
pour eux très difficile notre point de
vue une autre c'est son pseudonyme sur
lefigaro.fr c'est un problème délicat
parce que l'acceptation de la différence
ça prend ce n'est pas naturel
il ya un dernier argument sur lequel
j'aimerais avoir votre point de vue
c'est le côté peut-être intrusif de
cette campagne moi je me disais si
j'avais un de mes jeunes enfants à qui
j'avais pas parler de ce sujet qui voit
dans le métro ma fille et trans qui me
dit mais papa c'est quoi un trans
j'aurais pas forcément envie que que ce
thème me soit imposée entre guillemets
par le la sphère publique et bien voici
justement parce que c'est le travail de
la sphère publique de données ainsi que
l'on travaille avec deux par les parents
oui mais tous les parents sont pas égaux
d'accord il ya par an et par an un
d'accord et des parents qui enseignent à
leurs enfants la haine de l'autre on
peut se poser
lol le rôle de parent d'accord et c'est
là où pour moi la dui si je l'avais
entendu dire de la part d'un
pédopsychiatre l'un des lieux les plus
violents en france dont on ne parle
jamais c'est finalement la cour de
récréation que disent les enfants entre
eux ils reproduisent le schéma des
parents or comme par exemple ils ont des
parents qui sont profondément
communautariste et religieux et qui leur
apprennent la haine de l'autre ils vont
distiller la haine de l'autre
bon bah du coup ça veut dire que là il
ya un vrai combat un vrai combat keita
combat de la société qui est un combat
qu'il faut mener
et il faut défendre justement et
minorité je n'aime pas ce terme parce
que ça me nord on est tous vraiment
égaux et ça s'appelle plus tôt c'est
l'exercice de la fraternité
notre conclusion alexandre je pense
qu'il faut laisser reposer
de mon point de vue la loi sur le
mariage gay puis sur la pma a été un
progrès sociétal et j'y suis je
le disais tout à l'heure favorables mais
je pense qu'il faut laisser à la société
le temps de digérer ces innovations qui
ont choqué beaucoup de gens regardez la
manif pour tous regardaient les bio
conservateur regarder les groupes
religieux quelle que soit la région ils
ont été profondément choqués par ces
droits nouveaux aux gays et aux
minorités sexuelles je pense qu'on
pourrait la lever le pied un petit peu
le temps que la société s'approprient
ces nouveaux outils
merci beaucoup merci pour ce débat un
passionnant merci à nous avoue pardon de
nous avoir suivis et à demain pour un
nouveau point de vue
[Musique]